this is living on the edge Kenny has to
get to the food bank his leg amputation
after an infection is recent and he
hasn't got his disability benefit yet as
a type 1 diabetic he should be isolating
but he has to eat especially with his
medication
so this former Tesco delivery driver has
hauled himself here one of many new
faces in a place no one wants to find
themselves I was in rehabilitation unit
amputation rehabilitation unit but at
the corona they needed their bed so they
just put me in a tempe accommodation are
you able to get enough food to eat as
much as you would like to be able to
this community center in white city is a
place for people down on their luck and
the virus has increased those numbers
the most dramatic change is the knees
for instance yesterday we gave out in
one day normal week we're only letting
this business be back do you have given
up for one day what we normally give out
on one week is dead we've spoken to a
dozen food banks across the country
reporting similar increases a lot of the
users are new previously self-employed
working moms whose part-time jobs have
gone many don't want their faces shown
Kim is here to collect food for a
disabled friend but having lost her
income from working in a pie shop she
might soon be collecting for herself my
job three days
and how long do you think you can carry
on for before you have to start using
the food bank to sell maybe because I've
been using some savings that I've had as
well so now the project has taken on a
whole new dimension delivery these boxes
are being packed up with supplies to
last families for four days this
cavernous space is Olympia and in normal
times it would have just hosted the
ideal home show instead of a glamorous
exhibition offering home designs this
hall is now dedicated to something much
more pressing getting food into people's
cupboards they're delivering to about a
hundred homes today but they expect that
daily figure to rise and we all think
we're struggling
Kenny's had to adapt to his new world
more than most it's difficult but I'm
getting used to it now I can't be
sitting around waiting for nobody to
help me I'll just try and do it myself
you know but he is one of thousands for
whom survival is a food bank
Jason Ferrell Sky News